when I was living in Tokyo I would
sometimes just try to escape the super
busy cityscape and go to one of the
ancient gardens that are scattered
throughout the city and really they're
one of the only places in Tokyo where
you can actually get a taste of what
Tokyo used to be hundreds of years ago
and where you can escape that super busy
city life because even though Tokyo has
been flattened over the years by
earthquakes and Wars and the Japanese
still have this idea that buildings
around the temporary and so this whole
city is just modern skyscrapers
everywhere the gardens are just about
the only old remaining parts of what
japan used to look like hundreds of
years ago so there's something really
cool to visit I definitely recommend
checking out at least one of them when
you're in Tokyo and since I visited
pretty much all of them I have this
obscene amount of footage then I still
wanted to do something with so yeah
let's go ahead and check out some of my
favorite gardens in Tokyo the first
thing that I wanted to start with brings
us to Shinjuku Station because I really
want to see Shinjuku Gyoen this is
possibly one of the most famous gardens
it's been depicted in so many movies
I think Makoto Shinkai is a big fan of
this garden and the surroundings you can
actually see the skyline of Shinjuku
from the garden but I think the the best
part about this this whole park is the
traditional old Japanese garden that's
in here it is a very sort of standard
garden aside from the fact that it's
extremely busy it's definitely one of
the most popular ones in the city it
centered around this large pond with
these traditional pine trees and Okada
comi these trimmed the bushes around it
what's special is that it has this
really cool Taiwanese pavilion and it's
really an amazing thing to look out at
the garden from traditionally Japanese
gardens don't do this Chinese thing
where you look at the garden from inside
a building but in this building you
actually have some of the best views of
the whole garden so it's a bit of a
Chinese touch to it
I was also lucky enough to go here
during the perfect Momiji or a Japanese
maple autumn season so the trees were
all beautifully red and just one of my
favorite things about Japanese garden
and switch this garden does really well
is that they use all kinds of different
trees which bloom and lose their leaves
at different times of the year which
means that you always get this broad
palette of different colors in autumn
what's also interesting is that it
features the pavilion from the garden of
words which is a really famous Makoto
Shinkai
anime film so it's cool to visit that
for a second and kind of look out at the
lake from that pavilion the same way
that the characters from the movie did
it although I think in the end my
favorite place of it is still the time
when these people win anyway with that
said that's just about a very quick
overview of Shinjuku Gyoen which is
located right in the middle of this
super bustling city area which is really
cool to visit otherwise as well
definitely one of my favorite parts if
not my favorite part of the city but
yeah I think it's time we move on to the
next place which is Kyushu buddy'
cunanan
which is not as well-known but it's
known as one of the most beautiful
gardens for sure it's quite small and
it's in this very skyscraper filled
Harbor area over here but it's it's one
of the best protected gardens I think it
burned down completely in the past but
it's been completely restored to its
former glory it's basically a very
prototypical example of a strolling
garden with a pond in the middle so the
whole garden is more or less just a
single path that goes along or around
this enormous pond in the middle with
all kinds of scenes alongside it like
these pillars there is a beautiful
bridge going over the middle of the lake
there are some stone lanterns it's very
sort of standard fare but I think this
garden is probably the best garden at
presenting all these signature typical
elements of Japanese landscapes in a
super small amount of space because this
garden really is absolutely tiny
and within Tokyo it's actually my
personal favorite for me the only thing
that kind of brings it down even though
it's sometimes really cool like seeing
that train in the background it's just
it's too much into this whole area of
the city where it doesn't really feel
like it belongs all the skyscrapers kind
of pull you out of the natural
environment of the Garnon which i think
is a little bit of a shame but it's it's
also a very unique kind of way to have
this gone and the only thing that really
is a shame about it is that supposedly
you should be able to see the sea from
this garden but as you can tell you
really can't see just buildings so yeah
that's just a little bit of a shame but
I don't want to bring this gone and down
with that at all if anything it's just a
beautiful oasis right in the middle of
this super busy area near the harbor now
on a very short walk from this garden
through Schiano may you can arrive at
hama rikyu garden which is very similar
name and i think quite a few internet
pages actually kind of mess these two
things up but there are very different
gardens how many queue is much much
bigger it's right next to the co-domain
area with some of the biggest
skyscrapers in tokyo and it has this
enormous lake which you can not just
walk around but which has this really
beautiful tea house in the middle of the
lake which I think works out really well
actually with that super enormous
contrast between the skyscrapers in the
background and all of the water in the
foreground of the garden so I think in
this case the whole mix between the
garden and the skyscrapers works out
just a little bit better if just because
the environment is a little bit a little
bit less messy but also just because
this gun is so much larger it features a
lot of different little ponds many trees
some areas even where you just walk
through these little winding paths you
kind of go through bamboo forests and
you have on these trees around the past
which is really cool
some of the more sort of laid-back and
less busy parts of the garden but I
should say this is definitely one of the
most popular gardens in the city as well
I think it shows up on a lot of tourist
guide maps and you could definitely see
a lot of people here and as you can see
it's also a really really beautiful
garden to visit when it's the autumn
season and all the trees are losing
their leaves and especially as the Sun
sets you get some really cool views of
this garden and I think it's also here
where I saw some of the most interesting
trees like this tree which has like a
split down the middle which the Sun
comes through here and there's also this
really really cool Japanese maple tree
right like this one which also has an
insane sky going on and it's just the
colors are just so bright it's really
cool to see this also nearby is Naga
King capsule Tower so if you're an
architecture nerd you can check that out
as well it's a little bit dilapidated
but oh well and there's also Hayao
Miyazaki's clock over here in shioma
which is a really cool part of Studio
Ghibli right in the middle of an office
district another garden that wasn't so
high on my list but then I visited
because it was nearby Thunder Dolphin
the roller coaster as you can see here
is korakuen garden which is really close
to Tokyo Dome city and is also another
one of these real ancient Edo era
gardens in Tokyo which is a lot more
forested it's much more dense and
features less of these or Conoco many
bushes but more of these general forests
and this beautiful red bridge with
really cool leaves around here and it
much more than many of the other gardens
it feels less like a walk around a large
pond and more like a walk through a
really cool forest even though I think
still a lot of the same principles still
apply it's really a sort of miniature
creation of natural scenes which is
really the focus of a lot of Japanese
gardens to create our natural kind of
environments in a very miniature setting
it also features this really cool bridge
which is really cool to see now the last
garden which I want to feature here
which unfortunately I forgot to record
when I went to it earlier
the cookie and garden and the reason why
this clip is kind of interesting is
because this is in winter after there
was a lot of snowfall and yeah that was
a lot of snow so it was really cool to
see a Japanese garden in this snow since
it's the setting that you know usually
see them in but they work out really
well regardless a lot of these gardens
are made to look different but still
look good in every single setting and
you'll notice that for instance these
stone lanterns look really cool and
there's a small layer of snow on them
and these traditional tea houses are
just so cozy it's really cool to see in
any case these are my recommendations
for awesome Tokyo Gardens the visits
I'll definitely get into more nerdy talk
about the background of Japanese gardens
again in my Japanese garden series in
planet coaster but I hope that it was
enjoyable to still see these clips of
real live Japanese gardens which were
definitely the inspiration and main
motivation to try and make one myself in
planet coaster as well I hope you
enjoyed and thanks for watching